yom kippur was this week
and it is the highest holy day in the
jewish calendar
a time traditionally of atonement often
associated with the fast
and um i don't have much more to say
about that except by way of segway to
saying hanukkah is not a high holy day
in any way in the jewish calendar um but
but we being from uh you know
we are a secular household who come from
different religious traditions
and um
and we you know we celebrated a secular
level both christmas and hanukkah in our
home and we have adopted a new tradition
associated with hanukkah which makes up
the epilogue of our book a one-page
epilogue so while we are not going to
continue to do excerpts from the book uh
going forward we you know we were doing
one a week per chapter um for the 13
weeks before the publication but the one
page epilogue um i think will make for
fodder for discussion for a little while
right so we have effectively felt some
license to tinker with hanukkah it being
a lesser holiday um and
our household being a non-traditional
one and so anyway what we've done is uh
in a sense a prototype we have tried to
make it meaningful in a way that uh
grows with us as the years pass and
anyway heather's about to introduce it
to you yeah absolutely um so i'll read
through them and then we'll just we'll
talk a little bit about um either each
of them or whichever ones we feel like
so epilogue to a hunter-gatherer's guide
to the 21st century
tradition and how to tweak it
in our home one of our annual rituals is
to celebrate hanukkah the jewish
festival of lights that occurs just
before or around the northern winter
solstice we like the menorah as is
traditional and each night review an
additional principle which is not
our family's new hanukkah rules so again
there are eight days of hanukkah if we
haven't said that it's their eight new
hanukkah rules day one
all human enterprises should be both
sustainable and reversible
day two the golden rule do unto others
as you would have them due unto you day
three only support systems that tend to
enrich people who have contributed
positively to the world
day four
don't game honorable systems
day five one should have a healthy
skepticism of ancient wisdom and engage
novel problems consciously explicitly
and with robust reasoning
day six opportunity must not be allowed
to concentrate within lineages
day seven precautionary principle when
the costs of an action are unknown
proceed with caution before making
change
and day eight society has the right to
require things of all people
but it has natural obligations to them
in return
so should i go through one by one or or
what do you what do you think here um
whatever you think i mean uh i always
like revisiting them i i look forward to
hanukkah and the um the celebration of
these things and what we do you know we
whatever dinner we're having that night
we don't have a special eight nights of
hanukkah dinners but um we discussed
that principle uh around the dinner
table with our boys yep as well
um so okay the first one
all human enterprises should be both
sustainable and reversible and i think
that that reversible word is
the thing that is often missing from
discussions of sustainability
and um and is often missing in sort of
more naive discussions of what it means
to be a liberal versus a conservative
you can you can be all in for progress
but not be interested in making change
if um that change is going to be
permanent
yeah and it really it's an attempt to
fix the precautionary principle which
anybody who has tried to to figure out a
way to operationalize the precautionary
principle realizes that it it's very
difficult to do right because you know
what um
if you interpret it very strictly it can
paralyze you and what we don't want is
to paralyze us we want to be able to
take advantage of you know
reasonable risks but we very frequently
find out that risks we thought were
reasonable turn out not to have been and
so the reason to talk about
reversibility
is that
if you make a change based on a
reasonable guess that the consequence of
it will be safe
and you
you do something that cannot be undone
if you turn out to be wrong you're
actually taking a much bigger risk than
if you've said well what we need to do
is build up the capacity to undo this at
the same scale that we have built the
capacity to do it right so the point is
you know at the first the first moment
that you invent an automobile that burns
fossil fuels and makes co2 you are
altering the atmosphere but you're not
obligated to do anything about it at
that level it's such a tiny alteration
that it's not significant
but at the point you ratchet up the
capacity to burn fossil fuels so that
you do start changing the chemical
composition
of the atmosphere you're taking a risk
that you'll change the heat trapping
capacity and so therefore you need to
build up in tandem the capacity to undo
it if need be and if you haven't done
that you find yourself where we are now
which is we've got to change it is out
of our control and it threatens to um
trigger a positive feedback in
in the arctic with the frozen uh methane
being released the so-called clathrate
gun hypothesis but
if if we had recognized the need to be
able to undo changes to the atmosphere
at the same rate that we changed the
atmosphere then the point is at whatever
point we discovered that this had been a
mistake we would already have on hand
the solution
absolutely
um
day two is the golden rule do unto
others uh do unto others as you would
have them do unto you
uh you know
classic of course not um
not something that generally shows up um
in a jewish holiday well but uh you know
modern you know modern judaism obviously
in encompasses the golden rule as do all
moderns and it has been invented
multiple times including rabbi hillel
has a prior version of what we now call
the golden rule and so the point is
societies that work have figured this
out as a basic principle and um
it is really important that it be uh
understood even you know again
the devil is in the details with all of
these things about operationalizing them
but right and then and they're they're
good
they function as single sentence uh
prescriptions in which you need to
understand that uh you know
conditions will vary and will affect to
what degree you should
uh attempt to make these real yeah
uh so
let's see um only number three only
support systems that tend to enrich
people who have contributed positively
to the world
and um i guess i would add to that day
six opportunity must not be allowed to
concentrate within lineages
right the uh
the idea that we should you know
recognizing that we cannot actually
achieve complete equality of opportunity
um because
because conditions vary
but we should be seeking to maximize the
quality of opportunity absolutely as
much as possible for all human beings
and part of the way that we will do that
is uh to
uh to
to spread the opportunity um across
lineages and also to ensure that those
who are profiting from um from doing ill
in the world uh profit as little as
possible yeah
this the point you know throughout the
book basically we're pointing to the
fact that we live in an evolutionary
system and in an evolutionary system
where you profit by externalizing harm
on to others that behavior will spread
and be elaborated in a system where
externalizing harm onto others is costly
that
behavior will dwindle which is exactly
what you want and really the question is
you've either built a system that
involves in a direction that's positive
or you've built one that evolves in a
direction that's negative and you know
how well you built it will adjust how
quickly it moves in those directions but
the real question is trajectory which
which way do you want to go and i think
i mean this is a this is a good time
probably to
remind most of the audience hopefully
but inform some
of
the idea that
to identify something as an
evolutionarily stable strategy to
identify that something has
uh has
has been promoted by selection and is
thus gaining ground is in no way to
suggest that it is either a good thing
or a moral thing
or that all conditions would
result in that being a staple strategy
so there will for most for many things
be multiple evolutionarily stable
strategies and when conditions change
either endogenous or exogenous
the suite of
environmentally stable strategies will
change as well and i'm reminded actually
one of the um one of the podcasts we did
this week about the book
uh was the realignment and i think i
think that's actually out now
a really nice conversation we had and
um
we ended up talking a little bit about
uh the
misapprehension that so much of modern
academic social science has about what
evolution actually is
that
especially i think sociology and
anthropology have actually taken the
sort of the social darwinist the
eugenics
uh version of what evolutionary biology
is and imagine that that's what all of
us who are trying to explain the world
to evolution are doing and it's it's
absolutely a hundred percent
wrong right so what
what things like eugenics imagine um is
that survival of the fittest is both a
stable state in which whatever is most
fit right now is most fit forever and
ever and also that
things like wealth are good indicators
of fitness and of course in markets
where you have things like opportunity
having concentrated in lineages the fact
that you were born wealthy may have say
absolutely nothing about your ability to
accrue goodness in the world nor is
wealth inherently a good indicator of
that
but more to the point is the idea that
there is no
stable survival of the fittest
everything in evolution is context
dependent and as the environment changes
so too does what the what the
appropriate measure of fitness might be
so i want to refine one thing here
wealth is not a good indicator of
fitness in any meaningful sense it may
lead to fitness in other words your
wealth gives you power to
you know protect your family and things
like that but um it is not indicative of
the fact that you have brought something
special to the table but it should be
right we should want markets that cause
that effect where wealth actually is an
indicator of having provided some real
benefit rather than having externalized
harm
so
one you know we've been very deliberate
in constructing these principles and so
the phraseology is often precise for a
reason and note that we say opportunity
shouldn't be allowed to concentrate in
lineages right that is not the same
thing as saying wealth now obviously
there's a degree to which wealth can
accumulate within lineages that is very
destructive in large measure because it
leads to opportunity and so to the
extent that the wealth is all
concentrated and that means that people
who might be able to do something useful
which should be rewarded don't have the
opportunity because either they don't
get the educational benefits or they're
too preoccupied sustaining themselves
but that's a bad thing and this and this
is the wise version this is the informed
version of what um activists talk about
when they talk about privilege
right and and so the point is there is a
there is a real critique in there one
needs to be really careful i you know
the more i think about it the less one
wants a world in which the um the
product of productivity in which our
gains are evenly distributed that's a
desperately unfair world and it doesn't
do good things and um you know this is
the the failure at the heart of
communism but there is an enlightened
version of well what do you want to
equalize and the thing that i think
separates these two things is if you if
you're a believer in markets right as we
are if you're a believer in markets
then they work best when everybody has
access to them right meaningful access
not just theoretical access but when
everybody has the tools to actually
innovate and bring things into a market
then the thing is not just access at the
consumer level right right it's that not
just access at the consumer level which
all americans have pretty much but
access potentially at the producer level
right that's the most important thing
and so if you have a market that rewards
things that are actually positive that
actually create meaningful wealth rather
than transfer wealth
um then uh
the reward uh arising because you've
innovated the opportunity has to be
spread most widely because then we get
the maximum
number of opportunities to evaluate and
the good ones rising then results in a
reward and that's how you get a system
that evolves to meet the values that we
claim to hold rather than one that is
constantly uh
running up against those values
that's right
let's see don't game honorable systems
um
maybe we've done that already but
well i would we have a game the
honorable system no we don't maybe we've
talked about yeah i will just say
sometimes with customer service you have
to be ruthless
customer service there's really good
chance customer service is not an
honorable system that's why it's written
that way yeah exactly
um but i mean this is this is one of the
things and we you know we have this in
the epilogue not in the end of either
the childhood or the parenting
relationship chapter but
this is one of the messages that we were
teaching our children very very early
and you know all of all of these we were
giving to our children every year you
know with hanukkah but
the idea that uh for instance
we as their parents uh have rules that
they may not understand but they are
they are
honorable they are intended to be good
and sometimes we will make errors
and when we make errors we are expected
to figure it out and change them or to
have or to respond to them when they
figure it out and change them but the
idea that they would game us and this is
true for any um parent childhood
relationship
if the parent is a is a good parent is a
good and loving parent
as all parents should be but of course
not quite all are
their systems their rules that they have
in place no matter how good they are
if they're honorable should be refinable
over time and that is much much harder
if the child is simply reacting to oh
it's a rule um i don't like it and this
is this is unfortunately a place where
we have lost nuats in the modern in the
modern world among especially um some on
the on the sort of what i call the
pseudo left the idea that if it's a rule
if it's a law if it came from the before
times whatever that means it must be bad
um is absurd and you know some of what
we're being handed down right now is bad
and is dishonorable and um and is not
worthy of being protected things like
customer service maybe in some cases but
um
but the idea that for instance the
founding principles on which uh the
united states were were based
they're to some degree outdated they're
not as up to the task as they should be
anymore but they are deeply honorable
and they have been deeply functional
actually it strikes me
so in the book uh we talk about the
precautionary uh principle and
chesterton's fence which turn out to be
inverse of each other and i'm thinking
actually
that there's another one of these about
how one addresses um
a dishonorable system a system built to
do uh harm or to
give control where it doesn't belong
and that it's the flip side of what we
say about immoral orders right you have
an obligation not to follow immoral
orders and you have no obligation
to uh treat a dishonorable system as if
it were an honorable one
um and uh yeah this is good yeah civil
disobedience and immoral orders are the
flip sides of each other i guess
yeah yeah or the response to immoral
orders yeah exactly
um
[Music]
day five one should have a healthy
skepticism of ancient wisdom
and engage novel problems consciously
explicitly and with robust reasoning so
this is kind of this is a twofer really
um it is it is both a
um that which came before um has worked
if it's been persistent and complex and
long-lived persistent long-lived being
synonyms here
but that doesn't mean that it's up to
today's challenges um but that also
doesn't mean that you throw that out and
just take whatever is new as an
appropriate response yeah and so uh the
second or last chapter of the book is
really about this puzzle it's not that
we don't like ancient wisdom we love
ancient wisdom but the point is the more
rapidly your situation is changing the
less likely that wisdom is to apply and
so the skepticism isn't like
it's not cynicism about ancient wisdom
it's a you have to evaluate each of
these parameters and whether they fit
our current circumstances because
uh
you know
how do you apply
you know the
moral tenets of the bible to twitter
right you know with
bots and
multiple anonymous accounts and d
boosting i mean you know the good
samaritan gets slaughtered
right so we have to we have to think
about these things and you know very
frequently the formulation that we
arrive at is you've got a value which
motivated a
uh prescription from the past the
prescription goes out of date the value
doesn't and the question is well how can
you do how can you uh protect that value
in the present circumstance without
obligating yourself to a prescription
that's inadequate absolutely
very good
um
okay we already did the next two so the
final one is day eight society has the
right society has the right to require
things of all people
but it has natural obligations to them
in return
this is um this is one about which
people will disagree um i mean people
may disagree with all of them but i
think the idea that society actually has
a right to require things of us
is is something that many find anathema
but
it is true
as long as the contract is a good one
yeah let's put it this way it has to be
true there are too many of us you can't
all decide to go hunt and gather and say
i i reject uh being part of civilization
i'm going to go back and do what i was
born to do if you if you do that right
the the earth will not be able to
sustain our population it will crash so
the point is we've actually signed you
up
for civilization and you can't opt out
of it right you can't go claim territory
or whatever else you might have done in
the past we pay taxes and we get
licenses in order to drive and
and such right however the point is that
naturally comes with the obligation that
the society that robbed you of your
right to go do what you feel like doing
has to protect you from certain things
right it has to protect you from the
predatory behavior
of powerful entities you know for
example well if it's an intact social
contract it's not theft it's not having
been robbed right right well the point
is you didn't have a choice but to sign
it you were born into a society and
you're obligated to be part of it
but that comes with obligations and the
problem for us moderns typically
is
the thing
is in breach of contract
right the systems that are supposed to
protect us and are supposed to provide
the opportunity that was the thing that
we got in exchange for giving up our
right to go hunt and gather right
those that capture is now predatory and
it takes advantage of us and so the
problem is the society is in breach of
contract and that changes our
obligations
to it
[Music]